uh this is going to be a little
different but i want to just uh talk
about where i'm at with this rendering
because all right so i had this error
with the rendering as you can see it's
now gone
and i just want to explain what that was
because i literally couldn't find
anything about it i searched
and i searched and i searched and i
searched and like i could find basically
zero information don't try to be
creative just follow the directions and
just do it
because because that was my problem i
was trying to get creative i was trying
to save up this most micro second of
processing power to do something a
little better just don't just eat the
cost and do it the way you're supposed
to man
that's that's the rule
i literally was not binding vertex array
0 at the end because i was thinking in
my head i don't need to
and
in some cases maybe that's true because
it gets bound before every draw anyway
to the correct one but when you're not
using it or when you're done you need to
bind vertex array zero or else you're
gonna get that error that i was having
less last episode and you're gonna
google it and nobody's gonna know the
answer i guess i can continue on with my
life now all right so that's enough
about that for now
the error is gone
i'm
ecstatic that it's a thing
now i did try to implement
some new
kind of some optional
upload methods and they need refined as
you can see i have this set to false
it's a little hacked to
just you know try the new version or not
and it works in some cases doesn't
others so we're sticking with the old
version for now
which is basically just interleaved data
i think to use this new one i might need
to
separate the data so that it's not
interleaved and then it will be a lot
better
but something about the stride size and
the offset when trying this new version
doesn't seem to take well so as you can
see we're not using
see the old version use a trip uses trip
pointer to tell you which ones the trips
go to the
the shaders you know and uh where is it
into these
but
the new one
doesn't have a trip pointer instead of a
trip pointer we have format
and bind buffer
and then enable and then tell which one
to bind to
well it's enables the same basically but
it just has separate calls but two of
them take the same offset up and i don't
know if i'm doing that wrong
all right fast forward a little bit on
the new things look i i've actually
figured out this new renderer setup with
using the stride so this 4.3 when i was
just talking about that uses a trip
format
and bind vertex buffer
so you want zero on this bind vertex
buffer for interleaved so this one here
it's called an offset like if we look at
the definition right here it says it
wants an end pointer to the offset
all right so you know i had the offset
in there
but a trib format is the only one that
needs it and it's just this classic
offset of for your structure the lit
vertex is clearly a struct this code is
all public in case you didn't know go
check it out give it a star all that
good stuff
all right so yeah you only need the
relative offset in the trip format
apparently i was i was trying to figure
this out for a long time and it looks
like we got it now so that should be
pretty good moving forward now i got to
go fix it in my tangent version here too
with uh here it is
so you can see i have an offset here
don't want that anymore i don't want
that anymore
and now my tangent version should work
so this is pretty exciting
you know when in doubt just go off a
working example and stick with it while
it's working yeah there it is for 4.3
working we can set this one to true
we can set this one to true and we can
just try some cases and if they don't
work we can always just flip this back
it's kind of the beauty of it here we're
just still deep in testing but version 6
is going good you know the next step for
me after this renderer works which it
looks like it's doing fine now
the next step is to put in
animations and skinning and i'm very
very excited about that
uh yeah so
it won't be long before you see this guy
or whatever model i put in here doing
little special dances or whatever
that's uh man this
camera thing is really best
well i think that's going to do it for
this episode very happy to be
kind of moving on with this i was
uh
almost gonna just like entirely scrap
open gl and just
start using vulcan but that would have
been like a bigger commitment than just
figuring out a few basic things
and i still do want to use vulcan
but
i'm still learning a lot of this stuff
so i want to get the the shadows down
and i want to get a lot of the effects
down
and once i have those in opengl then
i'll start expanding other renderers
this is
as i've said
ultimately a big learning experience for
me and anyone else that's kind of
following the journey a little bit maybe
for you too so i think we're about ready
to merge this renderer
back into the original kind of using the
just the unnamed v06 as the one that all
these get merged into
and when this looks like it's ready to
be released we're going to move it to
staging
catch you guys later take care of
yourselves keep going
[Music]
you